liberals are sure they're in the
reality-based community and anybody who
disagrees with them is either has a bad
brain or in some other way rejects
empiricism and science and that they are
the only ones working with the building
box of facts and reason and I call
[ __ ] on that hi I'm Nick Gillespie
with Reason TV and today we're sitting
down with Jonah Goldberg of National
Review Online and the author most
recently of the tyranny of cliches how
liberals cheat in the war of ideas Jenna
thanks for joining us thanks for having
me
so let's get right to it what
describe your why did you write this
book about the tyranny of cliches well
you know as I say in the very beginning
you know the best news there is is being
annoyed you know as you probably know as
well it's much easier to write something
if something pisses you off right and I
go to a lot of college campuses and I
always I learned that these kids are
taught to be incredibly skeptical of
ideologies you say something
conservative or libertarian they're you
know their spider sense starts tingling
but they'll often talk to you in these
incredibly potted stupid cliches you
know they'll say things like better 10
guilty men or go free than one in US and
go to jail and then they'll sit down
like they've said something interesting
right and Ivan you particularly you talk
about the play on the Voltaire line
about I'll just you know I disagree with
what you're saying but I'll defend your
right to say right and they sit down
there I was he lying you know they're
not gonna take a bullet for me and they
say after the speech so who gives a
rat's ass and and they're not responding
anything I said it's way to die ok so
there I mean there's you know there's a
tyranny of cliches I mean a cliche is a
cheap way of not really having to think
much about things and stuff like that so
how does how do liberals play ok so as
you know because we've gone butted heads
on the libertarian versus conservative
stuff many times libertarians and
conservatives and in fairness Marxists
and socialists you know admit their
ideological biases they say these are
the things that are important to me I'm
a defender of ideology rightly
understood I think ideology is simply
your checklist of priorities that you
bring to
new events you know you say does it
expand freedom does a constrained
freedom is it respect the dignity of an
individual you go down the list of
things you respect or don't respect
right and we admit it and we have
arguments about it and we get really
dorky about it Hayek versus Burke versus
I and Rand and all that kind of stuff
it's like Dungeons & Dragons dorks but
free Drake I versus Alma Hayek exactly
right one's easier on the eyes one's
better to read and I didn't realize that
Friedrich Hayek had written anything and
liberals don't have that orientation and
what define liberal because I mean it's
interesting that you talk about
socialists or Marxist because I tend to
agree with you they are ads as much
outside of the normal political
conversation so they have I mean they're
in a minority and they're in a kind of
marginal position what but a lot of
conservatives certainly conservatives
the National Review throw around
socialist or you know people at reason
probably do as well what's what's a
liberal to you well I think a liberal is
basically I mean a classical liberal
view right more or less and in deserves
that me and they're interesting debates
we had there but a liberal is basically
the latest label that we apply to the
progressives and the progressive
tradition and I trace this back to the
progressive intellectual tradition it
comes out of pragmatism there was this
whole approach well William James John
Dewey Horace Cowen where they took this
approach and they said we don't believe
in ideology we don't believe in
philosophy we're gonna take the
pragmatist razor we are going to go
everything simply on the facts and the
data and all those so I mean really
you're talking about in a contemporary
context this I mean the New Republic as
a magazine truth it expressly came out
of that that movement that point of view
but then it's it's kind of a main
liberal mainstream mainstream liberalism
Baldrick's a lot of prog men president
is a archetypal although going to his
credit will from time to time actually
admit that he is a progressive he
doesn't think it has any in any way
contradicts simply doing the right smart
technocratic well and and to talk about
kind of cliches of ideologies one of the
people that you talk about is Andrew
Sullivan who has wrote a book a few
years ago called the conservativism of
debt or the commune Oh reclaiming the
conservative soul he talked about the
conservativism of
right and his cliche kind of that you
take issue with this kind of interesting
to me he said you know that
conservativism is actually about
epistemological humility that it's you
you have to be in doubt of the ability
to know things if you're a conservative
but you actually attack him as being you
know it's kind of faking it so talk a
little bit about that and how that plays
into the larger conceit of the chair as
I believe I said in the book I find the
argument he makes very compelling and it
really rings a bell with me I like
Oakshott I like Burke I like all these
guys but first of all anybody who's
actually read Sullivan you know he's
often an error but never in doubt when
he writes things right I mean he's a
very strident declarative categorical
writer who's convinced that he's right
on the gynecological spelunking and
Sarah Palin and all that method but he
has this refrain which you often hear is
that you can't it's I think it's a line
from Oakshott you know you can't you
can't walk through life if you're
looking down at a book and it's this
deep skepticism and he recounts this
tale that Oakshott tells I think he
mangles Oakshott on this but he tells
this tale about how you know you can't
learn what's a truly important in life
from books and this is a really strange
sort of approach to human wisdom right
the idea that you cannot have you cannot
convey wisdom through books right
because all ideology really boils down
to is accumulated wisdom it doesn't mean
that it's always right you have to be
able to revision but you know Hayek
thinks that there's a lot of accumulated
wisdom and that as a libertarian and as
a conservative we would both agree that
that there is an empirical historical
case for the for human freedom and
markets and all of the rest and one of
the ways we believe these things is
because we've read about them in books
and so the idea that somehow you cannot
outsource some of your intelligence some
of your knowledge so books it strikes me
as ludicrous but that's sort of the
upshot of the argument that he's making
is that we can't do that you know
another one of the the book which is you
know when I when I first heard about it
and when I first got in the mail I was
like okay this is gonna be a real a real
kind of flimsy clip job and in fact like
liberal fascism whether you agree with
it or disagree with it's heavily
researched you know and a serious
attempt
Appl with stuff which i think it's
really great one of it so there's a
bunch of different large areas you talk
about cliches one is liberals constantly
say conservatives are anti science why
is that a cliche what what lazy thinking
do you think is going through that well
first of all they the tendency and
they're obviously concerned there are
conservatives on the right i mean the
anti evolution crowd is i think is
ridiculous and all of that kind of stuff
but the the argument the form of
argumentation you get from the left is
essentially that you're anti science if
you disagree with us about a certain
bunch of certain public policy you know
options existence of the problem or the
proposed solutions i mean whether you
talk about marxist or progressive as a
river there is this this is written into
there sort of DNA is this presumption
that they're on the side of science and
sometimes they have good science on
their side and sometimes they don't
sometimes they actually practice what
Hayek called scientism right which is a
Miss if it's a category error right it's
miss applying the authority of science
in two realms where it doesn't belong
and that's a lot of what technocracy was
and all that right but more often than
not what they're really just simply
doing is they're saying if you disagree
with our preferred public policies
you're anti science as if you know on
like global warming for instance I'm
willing to concede that there is global
warming I'm willing to concede that man
plays some role in it I'm not willing to
concede it's the problem that they think
it is and I'm certainly not willing to
concede that therefore we must embrace
the sort of new Malthusian wet blanket
approach to the economy why can't we
just try to fix it right I mean I'd
rather fix it and they think that if you
don't go in lockstep with them on every
single one of these things you're anti
science but now what do you do with you
know I mean there are high-profile
conservatives who are anti evolution and
challenge the idea that Darwinian
evolution happens over the long scale
you know long paths of history or short
one I mean a Republican presidential
nominees and I'm not sure that any
ideological or intellectual movement
should be held responsible for the
politicians who claim Earth's mantle but
I mean we had Republican debates where
you know guys were raising their hand
side
believe in evolution is that I mean is
that a legitimate attack that more
people who call themselves conservatives
seem to be skeptical about things that
seem to be settled in scientific areas
yeah look is there something going on on
the right that I think is sort of a
double-edged sword right it's on the one
hand it's I think it's a healthy
skepticism on the other hand that
sometimes applied in areas that we I
don't think need all that much
skepticism right and so on the evolution
stuff I'm not with them on this stuff
but part the problem is is that there's
very few public policy implications that
this is basically asking people are you
going to deny your faith in public you
know it's a it's sort of a it's a shitty
catch-22 kind of question a people on
and we can I mean if Michele Bachmann
can't change if she can't get rid of the
minimum wage she's not going to be able
to get rid of survival of the fittest
right right yeah and the idea that
somehow there's a huge public policy
component to affirmations of evolution
but why can't it be why can't we say
someone is anti science if they are anti
nuclear power or anti DDT or anti
vaccine anti vaccine I mean it seems to
me that these are you know there's a so
let's I mean I agree and I think that
that's one of the powers of the book is
that it forces everybody regardless of
your ideology to kind of check your
cliches but then is this a liberal issue
or is it I mean simply that you're
bringing it to light because you're a
conservative and you're looking at the
way liberals critique you because there
are conservatives you know I'm thinking
of something which is consistent from
the Bush administration to Obama both of
whom pledged to do
science-based radical planning something
like Plan B the after the after morning
pill which is not an abortion pill it's
a super-duper birth control pill they
the FDA under both of them said hey
let's just make this over-the-counter
each of them have faltered on that is
this I mean is cliche mongering really a
bipartisan or a trans partisan issue it
is absolutely a bipartisan transport
everybody does it everyone has their
buzz phrases
everyone has their bumper stickers
there's [ __ ] flung from all sides
that's not my point
yeah my point is is that when I have an
argument with you it's understood that
you
things from a certain perspective you've
that you value certain you know
priorities more than I do and vice versa
and so but because we share enough of
these priorities we can have a really
interesting argument but where to draw
these lines you know the one of the
cliches is that conservatives and really
libertarians right because from the LES
point of view the right is sort of
monolithic which is annoying but that
we're dogmatic we have this dogma market
fundamentalists we're dogmatic we're
closed-minded and first of all calling
libertarians close my name is a really
odd rhetorical thing but no it's done
and but the reality is is the dogmas the
other way around right the left is
dogmatic because they don't even
question the role that government should
do good where it can when it can
whenever it can and so as I say
somewhere in there I'm not saying that
these are all the cliches in the world
I'm not saying that only liberals my
point is is that that liberals because
they don't they're the ones suffering
from epistemic closure they're the ones
who are sure they're in the
reality-based community and anybody who
disagrees with them is either that's a
bad brain or is insourcing by ideology
or as a fundamentalist or in some other
way rejects empiricism and science and
that they are the only ones working with
the building box of facts and reason and
I call [ __ ] on that my argument is
that they all have ideologies and it's
healthier and more honest to admit you
have it and that way someone can judge
where you're coming from and and
certainly we're in a world now where
whether you want to or not people are
gonna be fact-checking I mean not just
fact-checking you but kind of
epistemological checking you out in all
sorts of ways who are on the broadly
construed
laughter liberal left of center who do
you think is is a serious kind of
intellectual that you think is is
running away from the cliches and doing
the kind of work you think everyone
should be I don't know I mean I think
Bob Samuelson certainly of mainstream
colonists is a guy who really just sort
of goes where the data try to takes him
and I think you know he's not really an
ideologist
right I know he I mean he's one of those
rare guys who seems to be right you know
he doesn't have a fully-fledged
worship in a Tron as much as I beat up
on jonathan chait in the book and as
incredibly wrong i think he is on this
question of empiricism versus eighty
hours and all the rest I do think that
he does go where he thinks the data is
taking them and he is a pretty he can
you know he can be partisan and all that
kind of stuff but I think he tries
harder than most to play it fair and
will break with his own side on certain
issues if need be and a Peter Bernard
who I used to debate all the time he's
be other New Republic he's on something
of a journey I can't quite figure out
what's going on there but you know I
don't have a very long list of these
people who's that who's the worst
malefactor on the conservative side who
is you know just the cliche monger name
names conservative supposedly liked to
do that yeah I don't know I mean the
easy targets are people like Michael
Savage you know and that kind of thing
and but he's also not I mean he's not
writing at the same level oh yeah yeah I
mean he's I would say what's his name
mark Gerson just drives me batty and he
in part because he buys into Michael
Carson Michael Gross ya the servant of
columnist for abortion oh right the
foremost champion of compassionate
conservatism which is buying into this
sort of liberal trope that the role you
know that the measure of someone's soul
is how much they support bloated
inefficient government programs and
whatnot I you know by most measures I
have no soul but especially by that when
I think of Jewish well you know let's
talk a little bit about the longer arc
of your career you were the original
editor of National Review Online you
created the site in what year well I
just signed up with Knight late I think
was late 1998 but I didn't become the
first editor of something real until
early 1999 yeah and I mean it's it's odd
because now the internet or you know web
sites are such a part of our lives we
forget there was a time before that but
National Review out of all of them
although the political magazines I think
not only had the first fully fledged web
site but also the best talk a bit a bit
about
you know where did that come from what
were you trying to do and do you think
it's worked well well on the editorial
side you know one of the things I was
trying to do was send a little bit of a
signal that this is not your father as
National Review anymore I mean not only
important big issues and I'm a big fan
of William F Buckley and all the rest
but totally culturally as you know you
know master view used to be you know
Latin puns and Chesterton quotes and
that kind of thing and the people who
were reading online tend to dispute
coastal and young rather than the people
who are subscribing the print tended to
be skew Midwestern and old which i think
is what when ice first started that's
sort of what reasons readership was to
back then and and so I you know wanted
to be more conversational more water
cooler and all that kind of thing and on
the technological side we had something
some real advantages one because the
magazine cain't was bi-weekly or
semi-monthly I can never keep those
things fortnightly fortnightly uh we
kind of had the staff of a full-blown
weekly magazine but with enough downtime
that we could actually allocate some
resources it was a much harder
transition at first for weekly magazines
to go to the web simply because they had
so many deadlines just getting out of
real magazine and the monthlies tended
to have really small staffs and so we
sort of were in this sort of a little
sweet spot that way and but we also had
this great advantage you know brand
names really helped in the early days of
the web you know and there was all of
these awful websites out there that you
didn't know whether you could trust them
you didn't know if it was real news they
were you know they were getting into the
media food chain and then blowing up in
people's faces people relied on it and
naturally we had that sort of
conservative Good Housekeeping Seal of
Approval and it helped us enormous Lee
and so originally it was seen basically
as a marketing tool more than anything
else it drove subscriptions for the
magazine and was successful in those
terms more than any other it might know
you know it's interesting we were
recently at a lecture by leon kass you
know and old and old beyond his years
critic even though he is you know a
old now and he was kind of complaining
about things like the internet that he's
breakdown they subvert traditional
hierarchies and conservative patterns of
learning but you know National Review
arguably more than any intellectual
magazine any thought journal has you
know has kind of flourished online to a
point where I know a lot of people who
you don't even read the print edition
anymore is there an irony there that you
know what conservative magazine really
was first out of the box with a fully
realized website and what does that say
about you know is conservativism opposed
is it really standing athwart history
yelling stop or is it sending a thort
you know a bunch of you know kind of
porn ads saying let's go let's go go go
it's a look it's it's a complicated
scenario right I mean first of all the
right has always been right the right
broadly understood has always been
better at new media technologies than
the left because the left own the
mainstream technology so this is stuff
like Direct Mail Direct Mail it's radio
radio talk radio and all the rest well
they were always pioneers I'm you know
VHS movie you know documentaries you
know we're very big on the right for a
while and I think this was sort of
partly the two groups that always
exploited new media the best worked or
not
pornographers and conservative you know
outfits and and naturally I have to say
to their credit from the beginning my
first meetings with the suits there they
said look the mission of the magazine is
the mission and if the magazine can't do
the mission anymore maybe it'll just be
a website or maybe it'll be will go
monthly I mean they were never said
national view doesn't exist if we lose
this paper thing even in the early days
but look it is absolutely true that
technology and one of the few pieces
I've written for Reason magazine was
sort of on this point technology is
vastly more disruptive than ideas most
of the time you know you know the car
did more to unsettle establish
relationships and communities in the
United States the Nietzsche has ever
done but you can argue with Nietzsche
you can't argue with a Buick right and
but you can but you won't win right
and the be what doesn't care and so I
think that one of the things that's
often left out in this and
think that leon kass who I have a lot of
respect for but I disagree with him on a
lot of things he's a spokesman for a
different kind of conservatism you know
the fundamental argument that I make
about conservatism is that you know as
Hayek says in the United States you is
the one country in the world that you
can call yourself a conservative and
still be a defender of Liberty
because conservatives are defending a
liberal institution the Bill of Rights
the founding of the country and all of
the rest and and one of those thing and
this is why one of the cliches get in
there you know we're supposed to be
hidebound and dogmatic and resist change
but we're the ones who are defending the
free market as much as anybody and the
free market is the greatest engine of
turmoil and change that there is what
the way the left defines change or
progress is expansion of the state
that's what why Matt Buckley's talking
about when he's saying standeth word
history yelling stop is the sort of a
galleon notion of the state as the
engine of history well let's let's talk
about I don't know their engines have
change or you know they're kind of like
those cheap solar things that you you
know you can turn a light bulb on or
power a calculator with a solar cell the
presidential election here where you
know we're stuck with Obama on the one
side and Mitt Romney on the other who
among us can contain their enthusiasm
it's you know what what's what is a
conservative what's a National Review
conservative to think because Mitt
Romney cannot be anybody's idea of a
good candidate for the Republican Party
but you guys are going to vote for him
oh yeah without apology I'll go through
yeah and and like what what what keeps
you in that tribe well I guess another
way of saying is what do I need to do to
put you in a third party ticket today it
would have to be a really compelling
candidate who has a shot at winning and
and are really really good so you're
saying you wouldn't have voted for Barry
Goldwater in 1964 well what other choice
was there
I don't die being do I be but he had no
choice yeah but he was bad but he was
the only alternative right you know
that's my point I mean you know the
buckley rule of the most conservative
candidate electable still applies and
what is wrong with me
then in terms from a from a conservative
perspective recognizing that I mean I I
know what I know what I think is wrong
with them but and is there any hope for
this guy
well look I mean the and I admit this is
trying to make the best of the situation
kind of explanation but I kind of look
forward to the days where there's more
of a transactional relationship between
the conservative movement and the
Republican Party or the president at
least right one of the things which I
know you won't disagree with me on that
got a lot of conservatives in trouble
during the Bush years was this embrace
of Bush as sort of an identity politics
avatar of our you know our spirit right
he's he's one of us so we have to defend
him and a general fairly repugnant
blurring of the distinction that if it's
good for Bush it's good for
conservatives if it's good for
conservatives good for Bush as if
conservative and Republican have no
distinction there are not synonymous
terms I would like to move away from
that I would much rather have a
relationship with the presidency where
we say here are five things and we kind
of debate about what those five things
are and then everything else is a
negotiation and I'm not only have to go
all the way to Nixon you know where
Nixon actually thought that the buck
lights were more dangerous than them
right and in 1960 National Review
pointedly did not endorse him did not
endorse Nixon yeah in the 60 election
well will the National Review eventually
endorsed Mitt Romney as the candidate
for president I think it I don't know
you know it's not my decision to make
but I mean I'm in them in on the
conversations but we haven't had the
conversation yet I would guess that we
would I mean the one of the things just
came on is that the enthusiasm on the
right to vote out Obama is so much
greater than the lack of enthusiasm for
Romney and there was a strong argument
to be made that that a lot of people
make that Romney because he is this Bain
guy Mia that Bain consulting is you know
where he's just he does he's mission
focused right if he gets in there and
Paul Ryan is basically running Congress
there it's conceivable that whether he
believes in it or not I mean let's
forget that and to some extent who care
we care more about what he does he could
be the mission guy who does the sort of
being capital version of implementing
the Ryan's yeah then the question is why
would anyone particularly a conservative
want to implement the Ryan plan that
increases federal spending by a trillion
dollars a year well there's that debate
let me ask in terms of the you know
politics and whatnot John Derbyshire a
longtime writer for National Review and
and online was recently fired for a
racist column that he wrote what was
wrong with what he did it wasn't for it
was not at National Review it was a
talkie mag and he talked about how you
know come on let's face it you know
blacks really are more prone to crime
you know they act in certain ways he it
was in the form of a letter to his
children where he was counseling them
look if you're at a place where a lot of
black people show up especially if
they're wearing you know hoodies and so
I could get the hell out of there what
was wrong with that that he should have
been fired from his association with
National Review well I mean there two
ways to respond to this one is you know
what was wrong with what he wrote
regardless whether it justified fire him
right right I mean I was I think was the
first one out of the block saying I
found it indefensible I do find it
indefensible doesn't mean everything in
it and you're not pulling the
undergraduate Voltaire thing no no not I
mean every single point in there was
wrong in fact much of his data was right
and but the conclusions he draws from
the data are not that are far more
controversial and doing it in the
context of the advice he gives to his
children that you basically here you go
you sum up these people by the color of
their skin I found I just find repugnant
and and basically indefensible it's one
thing to say that this is sort of my
rule of thumb it's another thing to this
is how I'm going to inform the
consciences of my children that's that's
what really bothered me about it
now the second question is what was so
bad about a buddy that had to be fired
by natural again I didn't fire him and
for years I defended herb who's written
incendiary things before oh I'm not sure
any as it were as bad as this on the
grounds that you know my vision for the
corner which I also created this group
the national review was always that we
wanted to show that as long as you were
right of center that there was this vast
amount of diversity disagreement we
actually hammered these things that we
have these arguments intra-family but
not just libertarian conservative but
different flavors of conservatives right
and in full view and in full view right
and you know it's not what a what the
editorial meanings are actually like but
it's the it's a simulcram of it and my
argument about Derb is we need someone
who is sort of Palio you know Anglo or
Anglo fit traditionalist literary and if
we got rid of Derb we would have to hire
somebody far less talented than to fill
that spot but at the end of the day the
controversial stuff that he was writing
was sort of mounting up and you know
there's a reason why we do have the
expression or the cliche if you like the
straw that breaks the camel's back you
know straws don't normally break camel's
back the reason they break again was
records they were the last thing and now
we've gone too far and I think that the
thinking among rich and Jack and and the
other people who made this decision in
National Review was that dirt was
getting a lot of attention for his
writings for publishing things in other
places that we would never print
ourselves at National Review and I think
that this is there was a long time in
coming and I wish it you know honestly I
wish it hadn't happened I wish he hadn't
written it I wish you know all sorts of
things but wishes don't win the day but
I think was the right decision what are
the you know what's an issue where
libertarians and conservatives really
have been pulling apart as least since
the end of the Cold War I mean it's
always been a you know a fractious
coalition at best what is the issue
between now and you know so the election
in November where there there is you
know 90% or more overlap you know that
where we're pulling in the same
direction I don't know I mean you have a
good as good a sense of this as I do but
I would say certainly Obamacare right I
mean
I think that you know the Mark Steyn
argument which is also my argument but
you sort of articulated it first and
better is once you go down this road to
Obamacare you're fundamentally changing
the relationship between men you know
citizen in the state you know you really
are achieving FDR's dream of turning
citizens into clients of the state and
that should stew the bowels of
libertarians if not more than
conservatives than at least as much you
know and and so it seems to me that if
the election becomes a referendum on
Obamacare that's a good way to keep that
coalition together and what do you think
is the biggest point of kind of
separation I think it's got to be some
version of either national security or
the drug war right certainly culturally
the libertarian movement I know I always
say you judge movements by what they
prioritize right and so while I know
libertarians have a million positions on
a million different things the stuff
that puts asses in the seats and gets
people to show up at rallies and gets
people mad is really national security
in the drug war stuff and and what is it
with conservative groups and I mean is
it is it actually a marriage of Mexicans
or is it these days these days truly
it's an Obamacare thing I mean well
there's one of reasons why I think the
tea party thing was so unbelievably
healthy right two generations three
generations of liberal social sciences
that whenever the economy goes tits up
everyone rallies around the state and
demands more from the state and they
were all expecting Occupy Wall Street to
show up and it didn't and instead you
get this mass populist movement that
cares about federalism in the
Constitution and all of the rest and
federalism is the real key right I mean
that is the way to really keep the
coalition together as you push this
stuff to the lowest level possible if
they want to legalize this in this state
and ban it in that state let them do it
that way and I think that's something
that I don't know if Romney really
believes any of the Tenth Amendment
stuff but maybe he does well Jenna
Goldberg author most recently of the
tyranny of cliche how liberals cheat in
the war of ideas thanks for talking for
reason to with Reason TV today I'm Nick
Gillespie thanks for having me thanks
you